I'm a full-time High School teacher and
I've taken I've taken a part-time EMS
job when I'm out on on vacation and and
I do some food delivery uh to try to
just pack as much money as we can to
this debt I'm afraid my wife's getting
overwhelmed by it what's going on man
you're pretty emotional right now what
are you feeling be so intense that she's
like oh you know you won't let us do
anything and and this and that what's
the payoff date if you didn't miss any
night schedule I I I I told my wife we
can do it in six months so manto man
here uh I love this intensity but uh
there this is a six Monon window it'd be
different if this were a sixy year and
you guys had to be that intense I love
the intensity I think you have to
downshift in moments like this when your
wife is giving you the signal you read
it man you've been married long enough